hi I'm Megan Rosen and I'm a staff
reporter at science news so I cover
everything from robots to dinosaurs but
this year I spent a lot of time focusing
on the Zika virus outbreak so this year
we've learned a lot about how Zika virus
can affect a baby's brain and body but
we don't yet have a vaccine so I want to
tell you about two approaches to vaccine
making that could have some interesting
results in 2017 the first approach is
being used by the army at Walter Reed
and basically they're making something
called the Zika
PIV vaccine and so that stands for
purified inactivated virus and what you
do here is grow up a big batch of zika
virus and then you kill it with
chemicals and then you purify it and
that's basically your vaccine so it
sounds pretty easy and it's a classic
way to make a vaccine goes all the way
back to don't assault can polio but
there's one big drawback and that's it
can take a lot of time and money to grow
up all the virus you need to make the
vaccine so another approach to making a
vaccine for Zika virus is one that's
being used by the NIH instead of using a
killed virus they're actually using
something called a DNA based vaccine and
so you use tiny snippets of DNA and they
encode for zika virus proteins so this
is considered a much faster way to make
a a vaccine because you don't have to
grow up those huge batches of virus but
there's one big caveat the FDA has never
approved at DNA based vaccine in humans
both kinds of vaccines have already
started working their way through human
safety trials so I'm hoping that we see
some results in 20
a team I think the earliest we can
expect to see a vaccine for Zika is in
2018 or 2019 two or three years might
seem like a long time to wait for a Zika
vaccine but in terms of vaccine
development it's a really short timeline
until 2015 Zeke was considered a really
obscure virus so it's been really
interesting this year to all of the
science and to learn something new every
day
[Music]
you